Ein wirklich super schauriger Anblick: Am
Roopkund-See im indischen Himalaya liegen
Hunderte alter Skelette.
Die Toten geben Forschungsteams weltweit schon
seit längerer Zeit große Rätsel auf: Woher
kommen sie und warum mussten diese vielen
Menschen dort sterben?
Nun wurden die alten Skelette erstmalig untersucht
- unter anderem mit Hilfe von DNA-Analysen.
Die Ergebnisse sind verblüffend, doch gleichzeitig
geben sie Fachleuten nur noch mehr Rätsel
auf… Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt
es täglich spannende Science-Videos, abonniert
den Kanal und aktiviert die Glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
mit dem Geheimnis der Toten am einsamen See.
herzlich willkommen!
Nicht umsonst trägt der Roopkund-See, der
mehr als 5.000 Meter über dem Meeresspiegel
liegt, auch den Spitznamen: “Mystery Lake”
oder “Skeleton Lake”.
Im Jahr 1942 wurden hier nämlich am Ufer
Skelette entdeckt - und das nicht zu knapp.
Es handelt sich um hunderte von Toten, die
Forschungsteams weltweit große Rätsel aufgeben.
Dazu der indische Wissenschaftler Niraj Rai:
“Es gibt viele unterschiedliche Annahmen
darüber, wer diese Menschen waren, was sie
zum Roopkund-See führte und warum sie hier
starben”.
Einer lokalen Legende zufolge handelt es sich
um eine Pilgergruppe, die der zornigen Göttin
Nanda Devi zum Opfer gefallen sind.
Oder handelt es sich vielleicht um Soldaten
oder um Mitglieder einer Expedition, die durch
einen Schneesturm ums Leben kamen?
Eine äußerst mysteriöse Sache, denn schließlich
liegt der nur 40 Meter große See ja in einem
äußerst entlegenen Gebiet.
Ein internationales Forschungsteam hat sich
jetzt zusammengeschlossen und Knochenproben
von mehr als 70 Skeletten genauer untersucht.
Dazu nutzen die Fachleute verschiedene Methoden;
unter anderem DNA-Analysen, die Radiokarbon-Datierung
und Isotopenmessungen.
Diese biomolekularen Analysen enthüllen überraschende
Ergebnisse: Bei den Toten handelt es sich
nicht um Verwandte und es befinden sich etwa
gleich viele Frauen und Männer darunter.
Höchstwahrscheinlich handelt es sich also
weder um eng verwandte Pilger oder einer großen
Familie, noch um eine Expedition oder eine
Armee-Einheit.
Doch der Bericht zeigt noch ein weiteres spannendes
Ergebnis Dazu der Forscher Kumarasamy Thangaraj:
“Erst durch die Sequenzierung der mitochondrialen
DNA von 72 Skeletten wurden wir auf deren
unterschiedliche Abstammungen aufmerksam.
Obwohl viele der Individuen mitochondrielle
Haplogruppen besitzen, die typisch für die
aktuelle Bevölkerung Indiens sind, konnten
wir dennoch eine große Gruppe mit Haplogruppen
feststellen, die charakteristisch für Bevölkerungsgruppen
aus West-Eurasien sind”.
Heißt also im Klartext: Die Genetik der Skelette
zeigt, dass die Toten nicht nur aus der näheren
Umgebung des Sees stammen, sondern aus ganz
unterschiedlichen Regionen des Subkontinents.
Eine Überraschung - sogar für das Forschungsteam
selbst.
14 Tote kommen dem Bericht zufolge sogar aus
dem Mittelmeerraum - das legt die typische
Gensignatur nahe.
Genetisch sind sie mit den heutigen Bewohnern
von Kreta und Griechenland verwandt.
In der kleinen Stichprobe der bisher untersuchten
Skelette fand sich sogar ein Toter, der aus
Südostasien stammt.
Auch eine Ernährungsanalyse zeigte, dass
die Toten vom Roopkund-See unterschiedliche
kulturelle Identitäten aufweisen.
Dazu die Forscherin Ayushi Nayak vom Max-Planck-Institut
für Menschheitsgeschichte aus Jena: “Individuen,
die der Gruppe aus Indien angehören, hatten
eine stark wechselnde Ernährung – die in
unterschiedlichem Maße auf Hirseanbau basierte-
was in Übereinstimmung mit den genetischen
Ergebnissen steht, dass sie einer Vielzahl
von sozioökonomischen Gruppen aus Südasien
angehörten”.
Auch zur Todesursache konnte die große Analyse
einige Fragen klären.
Bakterielle Erreger als Todesursache können
es beispielsweise nicht gewesen sein, so die
detaillierten Untersuchungen.
Ausgeschlossen werden kann auch, dass die
Toten bei einem einzigen Ereignis zur selben
Zeit umgekommen sind.
Die Laboranalysen zeigen, dass zwischen den
Toten aus dem Mittelmeerraum und den Toten
aus Indien rund 1000 Jahre liegen: Im 17.
bis 20.
Jahrhundert kam wohl die Gruppe aus dem Mittelmeerraum
zu Tode - der Tod der indischen Gruppe passierte
dagegen bereits im siebten bis zehnten Jahrhundert.
Mindestens zwei Ereignisse, die unabhängig
voneinander vorgefallen sind, müssen also
zu den Skeletten vom Roopkund-See geführt
haben.
Bezüglich der indischen Toten äußert das
Autoren-Team in der aktuellen Studie eine
Vermutung: “Der Roopkund-See liegt zwar
an keiner großen Handelsroute, aber er ist
Teil einer Pilger-Route – der Nanda Devi
Raj Lat-Wallfahrt, die noch heute alle zwölf
Jahre stattfindet”.
In Tempeln der nahen Umgebung wurden Inschriften
gefunden, die nahe legen, dass diese Pilgerreisen
bereits vor 1.200 Jahren stattgefunden haben.
Bei solch einer Wallfahrt könnte zumindest
ein Teil der indischen Toten umgekommen sein.
Ein Rätsel dagegen bleibt, wie die zweite
Gruppe aus dem Mittelmeerraum umgekommen ist.
Unwahrscheinlich, dass auch sie Teilnehmer
einer hinduistischen Reisegruppe gewesen sind.
Dazu heißt es in der Studie: “Stattdessen
sprechen die Daten dafür, dass wir hier eine
Gruppe von nicht miteinander verwandten Männern
und Frauen haben, die während der Zeit der
Ottomanen-Herrschaft im östlichen Mittelmeerraum
geboren wurden.
Doch warum kamen sie an den entlegenen See
und wie kamen sie dort um?
Diese Fragen müssen durch weitere Untersuchungen
geklärt werden.
Die Analysen zeigen jedenfalls, dass Menschen
aus der ganzen Welt Interesse am Roopkund-See
im Himalaya hatten und als Besucher zu ihm
kamen.
Es bleibt also weiterhin sehr sehr mysteriös.
Ein Mysteriöses UFO an der Sonne?
Oder etwas ähnliches hat Neugierzone entdeckt.
Was ist das?
Anklicken, anschauen und den Kanal mit zahlreichen
sehr mysteriösen Videos anschauen.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!